Now that we remember what these operators do--this is actually doubling y
by moving it one position to the left in binary.
This is halving y or rounding down and halving y for x.
You may recall that this percent sign is the modulus operator.
What this is saying is take x, divide it by 2 and tell me what the remainder is.
If it's 1 then do this.
What does it mean for a remainder to be one? It means that it's an odd number.
Whenever x is odd, it adds y to z.
Then no matter what it doubles y, halves x, and goes back to the loop
and continues doing this until x is 0.
Unless this is obvious to you, this may seem a little bit magical again.
Why would this actually be equivalent to naive?
Why would this actually be computing multiplication?
Let's just make sure that it does first.
Let's print russian(14, 11).
We'll run that and see what it gives us--154. All right.
That is, in fact, 14 * 11.
We're going to need to step through and try to understand why it works out the way that it does.
If we give russian the input (14, 11),
it's going to assign these to x and y and start off the z at 0.
Let's take a look at that. Now it's going to go through the while loop.
On each iteration, it's going to check to see whether x is odd or even.
If it's odd, then it's going to add y to z.
We start off at 14, which is not odd.
What does it tell us to do? It tells us to double y and halve x.
We get down to 7, 22, and 0 remains 0.
The next time through we see that x is odd,
so we add y into z. Makes it a 22.
We halve x and double y.
In this case halving and rounding down.
That gets us a 3 and a 44.
The next time through the while loop we see that x is 3, which is odd.
That tells us to add 44 into z, giving it a total of 66.
Then we halve x, rounding down and double y.
Go back up to the top of the while loop, we see x is odd again.
We add y into z. Then we halve x, rounding down and double y.
At which point x becomes 0, and it returns the value of z,
which lo and behold is 154. It seems to have done the right thing.
What we've really done here is we've added several values of y.
As x is counting down, each of the times x becomes odd we add those together.
It ends up being the sum of those three numbers.
You have to admit that's kind of cool, right?
It's somehow doing the equivalent of 14 * 11, but not the way we would normally do it.